[Music]
seven years ago Washington and Colorado
became the first States to legalize
recreational marijuana since then that
list of states and the size of the
market has only grown estimates say the
legal marijuana industry in the US will
hit thirteen point 1 billion dollars in
total value this year in three years
that number is projected to climb to
twenty-two point two billion the growing
market includes product options such as
cannabis candy but now there's brewing
interest in something new
cannabis infused beer CBS News
correspondent Barry Petersen took a
closer look the answer my friend is
blowin in the wind when it's a
Clydesdales
it's about Budweiser whatever you know
climb on when it's the Rockies
it's about Coors famous beers available
at a grocery store mini mark or nearby
bar now comes cereal the beer almost no
one has heard of for sale almost nowhere
except marijuana shops in Colorado
because this is beer with the alcohol
taken out and pot put in created by
Keith dia and his wife Jodi
we're excited number one that our dream
is coming true but number two to offer
people to a true alternative to alcohol
it starts when via mixes beer and a
building behind his house with his
special recipe I used a mixture of blood
orange peel and Valencia orange peel to
get a very nice fruity taste and smell
but he's no ordinary backyard brewer he
got a PhD in brewing science by studying
in Belgium and while at Molson Coors he
invented blue moon that made craft beer
mainstream so when he makes a beer
prediction thus to pay attention we
honestly think that Sarah is going to
kickstart the cannabis craze and turn it
into a legitimate industry that no
longer has that stigma associated with
it it starts at this Denver facility
with bags of marijuana so if I walked
into a pot shop I'd probably buy
something
looks a lot like this very similar the
pot is crushed to dust then liquefied
under the watchful eye of Eric Knudsen
CEO of the production company Han core
from the liquid they extract the THC
that's what creates a high finally in
the VAT and the THC is infused into the
non alcohol beer when you close your
eyes and imagine who's buying that who's
your audience the first place that look
is right here it's a perfect product for
myself this gives you an alternative to
drinking alcohol but the complicated
chemistry may be the easiest part much
harder is marketing it under Colorado
law it can only be sold at a pot shop
and only consumed in private like inside
a home but even so says Stephanie Wilson
editor-in-chief of sensi magazine it's a
product Colorado may like a lot our
people are gonna really buy it oh god I
see it working like gangbusters in
Colorado a because we have such a strong
craft beer market just a lot of people
who are connoisseurs of beer and so I
believe that there is definitely a
market for it and its new and it's novel
ten states and the District of Columbia
have legalized recreational marijuana
with varying restrictions and that has
encouraged other companies to get into
the cannabis beer market the first was
to roots in California but since pot is
still illegal under federal law the
products cannot be shipped across state
lines not so in Canada where pot is now
legal across the nation brewers like
Molson Coors are investing big time to
make pop beer there and expecting sales
in the billions of dollars what we want
is the effect of the cannabis keith via
sees a day when cannabis beer will be
the best way to get high what's
different to say I'm having a marijuana
cigarette as opposed to having a beer
with the guys well yeah anymore
any kind of smoking is really not
socially acceptable and having a beer
with cannabis is socially acceptable
you can even toast people with our beers
because in the cannabis world there
gummies and chocolates but let's face it
when people are getting married you
can't toast the bright in the groom with
a gummy bear there may even be wine and
whiskey with marijuana instead of
alcohol which could make cannabis the
new way to say Cheers
for CBS this morning Saturday Barry
Petersen Denver